تحدثت في بدايه حوارنا عن مساله اعاده
الثقه للشارع واضح ان هناك ازمه ثقه مع
الشارع واللي اهتزت بعد كل ما شهده
البرلمان السابق من احداث في ذروه
الاستقطاب السياسي بين الكتل النيابيه
وانت ذكرت انه اولوياتكم استعاده الثقه
بالبرلمان في خطه لذلك ما هي خطتكم
لاستعاده هذه الثقه
الخطه هو العمل التشريعي جاد في استعاده
الثقه عندما يلاحظ الشعب وان البرلمان
يعني يقوم بصلاحياته على احسن وجه وما
يتوافق مع الاراده الشعبيه عند ذلك سوف
نسترد ثقه الشعب في الموصل البرلمانيه
فبنعتقد انه في ايه انتخابات قادمه اذا
عادت ثقه الشعب في البرلمان سنشهد نسب
اكبر تذهب للتصويت اكثر من 11 او 15%
لا اكيد دور ربما بعض الاحزاب التي قاطعت
الانتخابات الفارطه هي نادمه اليوم لانها
لم تشارك في الانتخابات واعتقد وانها سوف
يعني
تقوم باستخلاص العبره من ذلك
واكيد انه في بالنسبه للانتخابات المقبله
سوف تشارك في الانتخابات لكن الا تعتقد
بانه اي خطه لاعاده الثقه او بهذا الصدد
قد يكون لها مفعول عكسي مقارنه بالبرلمان
السابق هذا البرلمان قد يوصف بانه هادئ في
اعماله الا تخشون على سوره البرلمان التي
ربما تعيده للصوره النمطيه عن البرلمات
التي برلمانات او نوعيه البرلمانات التي
يجب فيها تنازع الافكار والرؤى وما يجلبه
ذلك من حماس كونه ما في احزاب ما في
معارضه وغيرها الكل مستقلون
او النسبه الاكبر طبعا
راوا بالنسبه لعمل البرلماني هو
الرائي والراي المعارض
ومقارعه الحجه بالحجه
ويعني تقديم الراي ونقيضه ثم استخلاص يعني
القرار الصحيح ولا يمكن ان يتحول البرلمان
الى حلبه صراع والى يعني
مسرح لتبادل
السب والشتم
والثلب لذلك
سوف تلاحظون بالنسبه لعمل البرلمان في
المستقبل والذي يبث في وسائل الاعلام يعني
مباشره في الجلسات وان العمل البرلماني
سيكون عمل صادق ونزيه وستكون
للنواب الحريه المطلقه في بدايه رايهم
وبطبيعه الحال هناك قناعات فكريه وهناك
قناعات سياسيه وكل سيدلو
يدلي بدلوه في الموضوع بكل حريه
[ضحك]
وبهاته الطريقه اعتقد اننا سنسترد ثقه
الشعب في العمل البرلماني